they gave me a Mooney Brown my character
too far I was like can we not do the
unit round please
how do you feel about people making you
like dressed up in a tutu every time I
ask for a duck in a barrel and instead I
got up every time somebody makes you in
a game
you're always like dressed as a fruity
person what are you trying to say Jack
you're fabulous
even my lipstick it's pink you should be
daughter yeah oh I didn't mean yeah you
went what level is random you all are
you set up in a pan so manly no fabulous
fabulous American animal fabulous this
is the best cake ever
Jake yeah I said I forgot oh that I got
stuck on a grapple me [ __ ] huh wait
wait one like a cat
oh god what stop it oh no I saw you try
to grapple me you holy bro you're a holy
breath what did you think I was kidding
okay losing blues and Ken hip hello
I'm too cool for being fabulous cuz I'm
fabulous when you get in that family's
[ __ ] do you like do the splits new job
yes
jelly of this [ __ ] I am jellied B oh you
double jumping piece of trash but what
did you know what did you mess it up
enough get it cut oh [ __ ] it is I got I
had my chance to win wrong way whoa
what's up in the ass eh I am a cutie pie
i an't
Oh expose that poster what yeah
rainbow map racin taste this is the best
character Fe beats a stupid bear guy cuz
I'm not getting hammered Oh what the
[ __ ]
come on I got some major wait wait I
made it I made it I made it I made it I
made it
come on No thank you for that little
boost like hey dude stall out look like
it Ned's gonna put it I put it back
adapt what you gonna do my dad yeah dad
Jer what are you doing dad you're why
you're afraid aren't you gonna do down
you better hurry down yeah oh god oh god
oh god I thought it was you crap
that's that's what the end that's I got
on tape that's I got it on tape
oh [ __ ] I hit myself what's up about
that one No ah keep doing this yeah oh
[ __ ] oh man no I'm not good at that crap
oh hey look at you want to rock it up
your ass no bruh Jonah - you a speech
[ __ ] whoa - [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dude okay you
gave that brush like wait up yet oh yeah
so happiness I always loved watching
this whatever Felix plays it's like uh
yeah what up [ __ ] and then oh no wait
uh shut up me yeah what up guys oh wait
up please
[ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] boxes come on no
scam II don't care gamers now diet great
I would say I wouldn't ready to turn out
a team [ __ ] I would read it active yes
my new hair do gir oh so manly shut up
your mmm nips
what does lock was anything from us what
are you doing but question is why do men
need nips
yeah that's racist some have a woman I
know the scientific reason but I okay
talking about I don't sound like a nerd
weights wait you know why there's nips
yeah the same thing when we're bored
come on come on
are you go ken ken knows that Ken's on
my level what what did you say oh you
you're so determined gonna leave wait oh
oh don't say Oh
Dogen sorry
Hey
that way now what's left suck my ass
thanks thanks for dad wait how did you
get the boost cuz I went through it when
you grabbed me look okay look what
that's me oh no offense but space I'll
tell you the quote it's not God how dare
you say that jacket it's called being
fabulous cop being fabulous alright yeah
you brought that upon yourself what you
like it I love it
I'm not the one playing as a for a
female okay shut up come back come on
Jack
you got this in peg you don't have a bug
in your way shut your face we have a
what I'll go Jack go go go shut up your
furry fine brother what what a [ __ ] uh
PD to the s that was amazing whatever oh
I won and I can't play no longer cuz
it's late oh no that's too bad too bad
did you understand we know where st. you
go
so quit it alright we have to give a
shout-out to the charity so we don't
have to but I feel like we should I see
you can buy team speedrunner or team
falcon team speedrunner all the way your
honor
teen spirit jack say it I'm not on the
team but taste free run away plate as do
gir that's not even her name all the
prophets know those go to charity I
check out the link in description I'll
see you on the Fame side high fives all
around